So now that we have a better
understanding of what this
Google Play Games library does
for us, let's start using it.
So I'm going to go to our
Downloads folder, and I'm
going to open up our as-of-yet
unused Play
Games Services folder.
And in here, there's a bundle
and a framework.
And we're going to add both of
these into our xcode project.
Just click and drag them in.
Again, if you're storing this
in a centralized folder that
maybe many of your applications
were using, you
might not want to copy items
and keep it as a reference.
In my case, I do just
so this is a nice,
little standalone app.
So I'm going to click Finish,
and they're there.
So I'm going to drag my
framework into my Frameworks
folder, and there you go.
Import step is done.
There are a few other steps we
need to do before we start
using this library.
The first is kind of
an obscure one.
I'm going to go into
my Info.plist file.
And I'm going to add
a new entry.
Right-click and do Add Row.
You can also do this by going
to Editor, Add Item.
And we're going to call
this GPGapplicationID.
And this is the 11- or 12-digit
number that is
associated with our
application.
And there's two way
you can get this.
The first is if we were to just
look at our client ID,
it's basically the
same number here.
So we can just copy over this
first numeric portion
of our client ID.
You can also get this from the
Google Play Developer console.
If we were going into
play.google.com/apps/publish,
and gets my number.
This number right here?
That is also the
application ID.
So you can get it from
either place.
Either way, I'm just going
to copy it, go back to my
Info.plist file, and
paste it in.
There we go.
And then the next thing we're
going to do is go
into this PCH file.
This is our pre-compiled
header.
And I'm going to add an
import statement here.
I'm going to add
PlayGameServices
/PlayGameServices.h.
I don't know why it doesn't
like to [INAUDIBLE]
it, but it doesn't.
And this is sort of a nice way
of importing this basically
into any file that I'm going to
use just to avoid having to
import it all over the place,
because at some point, you'll
probably forget.
I suppose this is optional.
If you want to skip this step
and just import it manually in
any file that's going to use
PlayGamesServices, feel free
to do that, as well.
I just find this is
easier for me.
Next, let's go back to our
IntroViewController.
And let's go to our
finishedWithAuth handler.
And this is basically
where we left off.
We had our auth object, and
we haven't done a whole
lot else with it.
Well now, let's do that.
Now, right above our
finishWithAuth method, I'm
going to create a new
method called
signInToGooglePlayGames.
And this is essentially a method
that we will call to
set up the Google Play
Games library.
And generally speaking, we
access this through a shared
singleton instance,
kind of the same
way we did with GPPSignIn.
The name of our singleton
class is GPGManager--
GPG here standing for
Google Play Games.
We're going to access this
sharedInstance, and then we're
going to set up our OAuth
information with this library
by calling signIn.
Now, there are two arguments
that we pass in here.
The first is a GPP
sign-in object.
So again, we access this through
the singleton method--
sharedInstance.
And then next, we pass in a
reauthorize handle or block.
This is basically a handler that
our GPG manager needs to
call if auth fails
for some reason.
Typically, this might happen if,
say, your user plays your
game for over an
hour, and their
access token has expired.
You might have noticed that they
all have an expiration
time of 3,600 seconds.
A less common situation might
be that a user has gone into
their account settings and
revoked their permissions for
your game, but your game still
attempts to, for instance,
submit a score to
a leaderboard.
So in both those situations,
the manager needs to
know what to do.
And in general, the correct
thing to do is just try
signing the user in again.
And so we'll do that by
adding in this code.
So if requiresKeychainWipe,
which, in general, means we've
got the signal that we kind of
want to clear out all the old
cache data.
We can call from our
sharedInstance, signout.
And this completely signs the
user out from the Google Play
Games manager, which means
that it drops all cached
information.
It does a few other cleanup
tasks to ensure that the user
really is signed out
on this device.
But then in either situation,
we'll probably want to try
signing user in again.
And to do that, we will call
GPPSignIn sharedInstance
authenticate, which is the same
method that gets called
when the user clicks
the sign-in button.
And again, if everything goes
well, it will pass the results
to the GPP sign-ins delegate
method, which is right below
our finished with auth
error handler.
So again, going back to our most
common situation of the
user's been playing for an hour,
and their token is no
longer valid, and they attempt
to unlock an achievement, our
GPG manager will get back a
response saying, hey, this
token is no longer valid.
It will go to its reauthorize
handler, in this situation,
requiresKeychainWipe
will be false.
And it'll say, OK, I guess I'll
just authenticate the
user again.
This will happen silently
in the background.
It's a silent authentication
that should succeed, and we're
able to continue like normal.
Don't worry if this code
doesn't entirely
make sense to you.
This tends to be kind of
boilerplate code that people
just kind of copy and paste from
our documentation, but
it's worth kind of knowing
what's going on.
And then all that's left
to do is call it.
And so, in our finished with
auth error handler, I'm just
going to say, you know, if
there's no error, let's call
signInToGooglePlayGames.
And that's it.
And so let's run this and
see what happens.
Hey, look at that.
That "Welcome back to Todd
Kerpelman" message?
That is the Google Play Games
library actually doing a fair
amount of work behind
the scenes.
It's taken my OAuth token.
It's used that to get my player
profile, my name, my
avatar URL.
And it's used that to display a
little notification message
at the top of the screen.
And all that gets performed
automatically as soon as I
call signIn on that shared
singleton instance.
And that's pretty cool.
I didn't even need to know my
OAuth information at all.
And in fact, if you'll notice,
this OAuthToAuthentication
object doesn't actually
get passed in to
signInToGooglePlayGames.
It gets all the auth information
it needs from this
GPGSignin object, which
is kind of cool, too.
So that's pretty good.
We're starting to look more
like a real application.
Next up, let's add a Sign Out
button and maybe perform a few
cleanup steps.
We'll do that in the
next lesson.